housing don't everybody its warned and
as we all know Avengers endgame is the
culmination of the 22 interconnected
films that form and exist in the MCU
Avengers endgame is the movie that is
supposed to wrap up the first 11 years
of the MCU story arc and these 22 films
and it did just that
leaving Marvel fans all across the
universe very very satisfied the movie
got a lot of things right did justice to
a lot of characters and gave fans many
scenes that we've been waiting for for
years now however there is one insanely
large question that was brought up and
not answered in the movie and before we
talk about that question I must issue a
spoiler alert for those of you who have
not seen the film if you have not seen
Avengers in game I will be talking about
major spoilers from the movie so here's
your chance to click away so if you're
still with me you may recall one
particular scene in Avengers and game
that left the door wide open for
countless possibilities moving forward
it's always tricky when you're dealing
with time travel and although Captain
America returned all the stones to the
original points in time when they were
taken they did manage to mess up one
timeline and that is in 2012 where Loki
manages to get a hold of the tesseract
and disappear and we are now left with a
question where is Loki this one scene
sets up an entirely different alternate
timeline one in which Thor never takes
Loki back to Asgard which means the
events of Thor the dark world play out
entirely differently the same with Thor
Ragnarok and the same with Avengers
infinity war Loki is now gone and he has
an infinity stone with him this
drastically changes the timeline and the
MCU that that Loki now exists in and we
have no idea where he went and what is
going to happen in this timeline now we
know that we're going to get a new Loki
series on Disney's new streaming service
Disney Plus so perhaps this new series
will help us answer this question after
Avengers infinity war one of the
questions that we were all left with was
is Loki actually dead and in Avengers in
game it really did seem like the answer
was in fact yes he died but they have
now opened up a new timeline in which
Loki is alive and with Loki getting the
tesseract and escaping in 2012 that
opens up
completely different future so now our
biggest question is what now where is
loki no doubt that this was done
intentionally again we have a new loki
series coming to disney plus not too
long from now but could this event in
avengers endgame when they went back in
time in 2012 and loki escaped with the
tesseract affect future MCU movies it's
a question that we're going to have to
wait to find out the answer to but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below where do you think
loki is and what possibilities do you
think that it opens up for the future of
the MCU let me know your thoughts and
just a reminder about my giveaway I'm
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark painting
of Fano spike glow by beau you can find
some of his other work at globe Ivo calm
I'll put the link in the description
down below if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof it's population
and all it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby